somebody once told me the world
What is THIS?
The "Try Not To Get..
..Satisfied Challenge?
*my channel is dying*
*why am I here*
*fookin doge appears*
We're really running out of ideas..  *chuckles*
You think I can't get satisfied?
Well then, BRING IT ON!
No, that's not what I meant, dam-- AAUUUGGGHH!~
Alright, here we go.
You can play along,
see if you du--
the GOAL is to NOT get satisfied
Now, I haven't seen anyone else do this--
I have no idea if it fucking works,
but let's just give it a go.
Oh...
Oh
OH
I feel it in my spine.
*Chop*
I- no- I don't feel satisfied
What the fuck is this?
Eew
Eew!
EEW
EEW!
it such a.. MEEUUH!
UUUUUUUH
This is cringe!
ugh
How is this satisfying, Danny?
UUUH
OOH
UH
He's pulling off
Just pull it off
Don't look...
No, stop, stop, just stop!
*Michael Jordan*
Stop it!
Get some help
I poured glue all over my hand
let it dry, and had an amusing time peeling it off
Well, how about you just go and play Overwatch instead?
How about that?
Fuck it, eh
Next one
Waterhole in Portugal
How is this supposed to be satisfying?
Ambient music and an artsy drone shot
Is not gonna do it!
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
Where is the satisfaction?
I need at least a penis, or a hole
I need something long or something holy
I need something long and stiff, or a BIG ASS hole!
Otherwise there will be no stimulation
*NSFW*
I'm twelve shut up
WOAH!
WOOAH!
Is that real?!
Nah, hell nah, there's no way that's real!
Is that real?
Whaat?!
Ohhhh
No
I'm not satisfied
I'm just amazed!
Is that
Is that mother nature's butthole?
*Farting*
*Michael Jordan*
Stop it !
That is fucking cool man
That is really cool
not satisfying!
NOT SATISFIED!
I AM YET TO FAIL THIS ONE CHALLENGE
créme brulee
*Sexual noises, food pawn*
*pff*
*laughing*
Another one
*SEXUAL NOISES*
*sigh* I don't... I think it's kinda gross
I don't like créme brulee
So maybe that's like my issue
You know THIS is my jam!
*man in video*  Anyway heres Wonderwall
*guitar playing*
I never watched this before
But let's see if I can keep up...
Somebody once told me
The world is gonna roll me
I aint the
*attempting to sing*
... the sheeeeed.
She was looking kinda dumb-- ehh.. finger in her thuuu...
I think i did pretty good
Shit - what is this - bees?!
Ughhh
That's holes!
How is holes satisfying?!
DANNY DEVITO
Ughhhhhhhh
UUGGHH THAT'S DISGUSTING!!
How is holes satisfying?
Someone explain that to me...
Nevermind...
Ewwwwwww
EWWWWWWWWWWW
Try not to get DISGUSTING challenge
That's what this is, Danny Devito!
Bless your soul.
Damnnnn! Eww!
Eughh! EEUGHHH!
Okay.
Why is -
This is interesting to me, 'cause it seems like
The line between satisfying and disgusting
Is very close.
'Cause uh- Surely some People find this
satisfying to watch, while others are just...
*Puking noises*
... grossed out.
Hydraulic press? Ok those are pretty satisfying
So this might be it
Is that a ru- oh, it's a rubber band
That's gonna be cool.
I just imagine my head being crushed underneath.
Am I the only- okay
oooh
OH
Oh-
Keep pressing, c'mon I want it to explode
That's it baby.
OOOH it's happenin.
It's happenin
eeuh eeww.
Ewww.
Looks like a finger-
What the fuck, is there a real body in there?
That looks like a testicle
Fuck, I thought I would be satisfied!
I WANNA BE SATISFIED DANNY
HUH? DON'T YOU LIKE ME ANYMO
An-- Pineapple? EWWW!
What the F**k?
F*cking - *laughs* - Hey! Hey!
It f*cking squirted!
jesus...
I don't... I don't think it's satisfying...
I DON'T think it's satisfying, okay?
I don't know - I can't... I can't explain why, alright?
Maybe you think so, I am not satisfied!
What is this...?
Custom Falcon resin pain.. pen?
Oh that's pretty cool, how it splits...
Oh that's...
Ohhhhh...
That's pretty cool.
IT'S A F*CKIN PEN!
Thai.. fried.. roll.. ice cream
*Staring intensifies*
the f*ck is this
Yeah that's pretty cool
Yeah - That's pre- that's- See THAT's pretty cool!
Wow - No. It's not f*cking satisfying...
Get outta here...
Slime in the (inaudible)
Ew, ew... ew, ew
Stop.
Its not-
Stop!
Ughhh the sound!
*moaning in disgust*
It reminds me...
EUGHHH what the f*ck?!
"The most satisfying video in the world MUST SEE"
Okay I'm glad, 'cause I can really see it..
wow.
really enjoying this video...
(sarcastically)
Oh wow what a great video!
See this sh*t
This is satisfied
Watching precise, pristine, high end machinery at work.
Now this is giving me a full- fully fledged erection.
(moaning)
Oh look at that sh*t!
Ohhhh f*ck yeah.....
Ohhhh yeah keep, keep doing that... F*ck yeah...
That is what I like!
Look at that sh*t!
Ohhh it goes deeper!
*moaning*
*ERROR NOISE*
I want that thing to rub me
*moaning*
Oh it's getting real nice
Oh its a helmet!
*Relieving Exhale*
Oh look at that Pizza!
Oh it's too much!
Nooo it's too much!
The tomato sauce - I CAN'T!!
*moaning*
Ew! ... Ew! STOP!
Yes. Now we're back...
No, yes yes yes....
thats beautiful...
Ohhhhh that's satisfying.
Ohhhh I feel so satisfied!
Not the paper, not the paper!!
What are you gonna do to that paper?
*in disbelief*
What?
How is he doing that?
Ohhhh noooo I can't, it's too much...
Danny you're taking over
I gotta...
I need like...
5 minutes...
Be right back...
*intimidating music*
NOPE
Well, that was: try not to get satisfied challenge!
Did I satisfy you this... day
Leave a like, if I did, and I'll see you, Bros, in the next video!
(chuckles)
This is so f'cking dumb, seriously...
STAY AWESOME BROS!